also man müsste uns ja fast alle ein
bisschen wecken aber ist das noch die
gleiche spd wie vor ein paar monaten und
hält eigentlich diese disziplin die wir
da sehen professor volker grund werk
politikwissenschaftler von der
universität bauen sie haben schon nicht
als die frage gestellt habe so von wegen
darüber müssen wir sprechen also ist
jetzt eine neue spd
auf einmal naja es ist ja nicht eine
neue spd aber es ist tatsächlich eine
spd mit neuen oder zumindest lange nicht
erlebten verhaltensweisen diese
geschlossenheit die man ja über wochen
ja monate erlebt hat in diesem wahlkampf
unterscheidet sich signifikant von den
vorangegangenen kandidaturen und
wahlkämpfen mit denen jeweils sehr
enttäuschenden ergebnissen so war sie ja
ich denke ändert naja das hat sich
geändert ja ich habe gesagt
geschlossenheit herrmann hat sich hinter
dem spitzenkandidaten olaf scholz
versammelt und man hat auch dessen
programm mit dem er ja angetreten ist
mit getragen indem man auf jeden fall
endlich auch dagegen agiert hat man hat
schien man hat ihn und das war ja auch
klug das hat der zuwachs auch gezeigt
dass hat die popularität von herrn
scholz ja auch gezeigt dass hat auf
jeden fall früchte getragen erinnern bei
unseren steinmeier an schuld an
steinbrück da war das alles ganz anders
es heißt frage der vorsitzenden saskia
essen und wollte norbert walter borjans
haben da ein großes verdienst weil sie
sich selbst hin angestellt haben haben
sie gewiss und auch wir haben gerade
gesehen camp in kühner denn wir dürfen
ja nicht vergessen so wohl eher kühler
die fresken wieder weiter vorn stehen ja
für was anderes ist ja noch nicht ganz
so lange her da hat die spd neuen
parteivorsitzenden gewählt und das ist
ja nicht scholz geworden sondern ersten
walter borjans sie sind für andere
inhalte angetreten als scholz das getan
hat und kühnert steht auch für was an
das so die frage war jetzt wie lange
hält das das ist die spannende frage wie
ist offen ich nehme wahr dass noch sehr
abgestimmt scholz auch wir hatten eben
schon mal gesagt die tonalität voll also
mütze nicht gegen ihn sagt die kleinen
parteien so ein bisschen grüne fdp ist
scholz hingegen hat gesagt nichts keine
parteien das sind unsere politischen
freunde auf der anderen seite erleben
wir natürlich die neue juso vorsitzende
jessica rosenthal die ins parlament
eingezogen ist die schon relativ klar
gemacht hat also was die fdp sich dabei
steuern vorstellt so läuft das nicht
oder eben also steuererhöhungen ist
wichtig und nicht entlastung da sind so
die erste news natürlich schon wieder
ein bisschen sich finde ich sagen die
finanzen aber darauf will ich hinaus es
ist schon zu erwarten und das war die
kühnheit intervention kurz vor der wahl
der lindner dann mal eben so nonchalant
als luftikus bezeichnet hat und dass das
parteiprogramm letztlich nicht tauge als
wir werden schon jetzt erleben dass
diese dass diese geschlossenheit mit
sicherheit doch wieder ein stückweit
weichen wird was jetzt das spektrum
erkennbar wird okay oder hasst die
finanzen natürlich erkennbar werden da
wird es natürlich schwierig vor allem
war sie ja die jungen ansprechen und wir
haben knapp ein viertel dieser 200 und 6
abgeordneten der spd geführt etwa 50
sind ja junge die da eingezogen sind die
er wahrscheinlich auch in
anführungszeichen inhaltlichen druck
ausüben werden und dann schon irgendwann
in den nächsten wochen monaten doch
spätestens auf den plan kommen sagen
sekunde sekunde sekunde wir wollen jene
inhalte die im zweifel deutlich ich
nenne es mal etwas einfach linker sind
als das was vielleicht olaf scholz
zusammen mit der fdp verhandeln würde
die grünen gibt es natürlich auch noch
und die vor allen dingen um das mal
abzubilden koalitionspolitisch er auf
rot grün rot gesetzt haben uns jetzt auf
die am pad und genau das ist natürlich
der spannende punkt und das war auch
schon der kölner team was na ja bei
einem koalitionsvertrag im zweifelsfalle
befragen wir die mitglieder das ist dann
natürlich schon heikel weil scholz weiß
das ist das wagnis der spd und das ist
auch ein super die offene flanke und
deswegen ist noch gar nicht ausgemacht
dass jetzt ganz klar alles auf schramma
ampel zuläuft und dass es am ende auch
alles gut klappt lindner die fdp
beobachten sehr genau so wie wir das
jetzt auch tun sehr genau wer meldet
sich wie mit welchem inhalt in der spd
jetzt zu wort in welche richtung geht
das steht mal wirklich hinter scholz
kann man das verfahren zu nehmen oder
sein stück weit könig ohne land klar ihm
ist zu verdanken dass die spd zugelegt
hat aber letztendlich war das nur so ne
das war wirklich nur so eine abmachung
laufzeit und dann kommt doch wieder die
alte die bekannte spd zum vorschein auf
die hat weder lindner und im zweifel
zeller habe keine lust